yo vengo representando a un grupo de
investigadores antárticos apasionados
por la antártica de nuestro objetivo
general es estudiar el rol de la
antártica en el clima global y los
efectos del cambio climático en la
antártica para el efecto en los últimos
cinco años hemos realizado decenas de
viajes a la antártica desde el año 2012
realizamos monitoreo de ozono a 800
millas del polo en un lugar que se llama
glaciar unión hace unos años construimos
una estación climatológica en la
península antártica en colaboración con
el instituto antártico chileno y el año
pasado construimos una estación gemela a
la que tenemos en la antártica a 40
kilómetros al este de san pedro' atacama
junto al observatorio alma a 5000 metros
de altura uno podría preguntarse por qué
construimos una estación en el desierto
de atacama si nos interesa la antártica
y la respuesta es simple la antarte que
es un agente climático global el clima
del desierto de atacama y el clima de
todo el hemisferio sur depende de lo que
le sucede a la antártica y la antártica
está siendo muy afectada por el cambio
climático para entender por qué la
antártica afecta el clima global basta
considerar las dimensiones del
continente la antártica tiene 14
millones de kilómetros cuadrados de
extensión y está cubierto por una capa
de hielo que en algunas zonas llega a
ser de cuatro mil metros el espesor
medio de la capa de hielo que cubre la
antártica es dos kilómetros eso
significa que la antártica tú tienes una
acumulación de hielo de 28 millones de
kilómetros cúbicos una cosa increíble
ahora ese hielo acumulado sobre la base
rocosa del continente que nosotros
llamamos hielo continental o plataforma
de hielo continental fluye por razones
naturales al océano pero ese flujo que
antes era natural se ha acelerado en los
últimos años sucede que la antártica
especialmente en la zona de la antártida
que llamamos la antártica occidental
está perdiendo mucho más hielo que hace
décadas atrás para que ustedes tengan
una idea de la antártica occidental está
perdiendo por año 125 mil
millones de metros cúbicos de hielo
cuál es el problema ese hielo al
derretirse está contribuyendo a la
subida del nivel del mar en todo el
mundo el nivel del mar ha subido 7
centímetros en los últimos 25 años y 10
por ciento de esa subida es
responsabilidad del hielo perdido por la
antártica
porque el hielo continental está
fluyendo más rápido contribuyendo de
manera tan significativa a la subida del
nivel del mar que lo que está pasando el
problema es que las plataformas de hielo
flotantes que rodean al continente se
han debilitado este ya no es hielo que
está sobre continentes sino que quiero
que flota sobre el mar esa plataforma de
hielo se han debilitado en las últimas
décadas y han perdido metros de espesor
cuál es el problema
la función principal de esas plataformas
flotantes es contener el flujo del hielo
continental como se han debilitado el
hielo del flujo el flujo de hielo
continental ha aumentado y eso está
contribuyendo a la subida del nivel del
mar la expresión más obvia de ese
debilitamiento de las plataformas de
hielo flotantes ocurrió en julio del
2017 cuando la plataforma de hielo más
grande de la península antártica en la
larsen se en un solo evento perdió el 10
por ciento de su superficie liberando
una expert
mil kilómetros cuadrados de extensión y
mil kilómetros cúbicos de volumen un
evento gigante que el responsable de que
las plataformas de hielo flotantes estén
debilitando sé quién está detrás de esto
con el sospechoso número uno es el
calentamiento global
la temperatura en todo el mundo ha
aumentado y la antártica por supuesto no
es una excepción el antártico occidental
la zona que más está perdiendo hielo
está hoy entre 1 y 2 grados más caliente
que a mediados del siglo 20 esa es una
de las razones que explica la pérdida de
hielo pero no es la única ese aumento de
temperatura a pesar de que es
significativo no alcanza a explicar el
debilitamiento observado en las
plataformas de hielo flotante hay algo
más ese algo más es que no solamente la
temperatura del aire sobre la antártica
ha subido sino que también las aguas
sobre las que flotan las plataformas
están más cálidas de lo que deberían
por lo tanto las plataformas de hielo
flotante están sufriendo lo que nosotros
llamamos derretimiento basal están
derritiéndose por la base perdiendo
mucho líquido adelgazándose y no
cumpliendo su labor principal que es
contener el flujo del hielo continental
ahora no es que el agua del océano que
rodea la antártica se haya calentado
mucho no es no es el problema el
problema es que agua de más al norte de
la antártica que por lo tanto está más
cálida se ha acercado a la costa de la
antártica
estamos hablando de volúmenes enormes de
agua kilómetros cúbicos de agua miles de
ellos que se han movido desde zonas más
al norte y están derritiendo las
plataformas de hielo flotante por debajo
quien no vio esa agua como es posible
que tantos volúmenes de aguas
gigantescos todos esos volúmenes
gigantescos de agua se hayan acercado a
las costas la respuesta es cambios en la
intensidad de los vientos en torno a la
antártica lo que nosotros llamamos
anomalías circulatorias cambios en los
patrones de vientos anormales que están
trayendo el agua que está derritiendo la
antártica y quién es el culpable los
responsables son muchos pero el
principal es un viejo conocido el
agujero de ozono el agujero so no es una
atenuación no natural en la
concentración de ozono en la parte alta
de la atmósfera lo que llamamos la
estratosfera que ocurre todas las
primaveras australes sobre un área que
supera el tamaño de la antártica
usualmente la máxima extensión del
agujero sono bordea cada año los 20
millones de kilómetros cuadrados como es
un fenómeno estacional que se da
usualmente como dije en primavera las
mayores bajas de ozono estratosférico
ocurren durante los meses de septiembre
octubre y noviembre el ozono es muy
conocido porque provoca
al disminuir saltos en la radiación
ultravioleta cuando el agujero de ozono
se da durante la primavera austral la
radiación ultravioleta especialmente en
locaciones cercanas al polo se dispara
por ejemplo en la serie unión a 800
millas del pueblo de la radiación
ultravioleta se duplica cuando cuando el
agujero sonó en septiembre se da
el agujero solo provoca que la
concentración de ozono en la
estratosfera baje a la mitad y eso hace
que salte la radiación ultravioleta pero
aquí viene el problema el problema es
que el ozono no solamente absorbe
radiación ultravioleta también absorbe
otras radiaciones solares incluida la
radiación visible y la radiación
infrarroja es decir absorbe mucha
energía solar
qué significa eso cuando los uno tiene
valores normales altos sobre la
antártica absorbe energía solar y ayuda
a mantener relativamente caliente la
parte alta de la atmósfera la
estratosfera cuando el agujero sólo se
da en primavera
parte de ese ozono que absorbía la
radiación solar desaparece y la
estratosfera recibe menos energía solar
qué significa eso tiene la tendencia a
enfriarse qué significa eso que el
agujero de ozono provoca una señal de
enfriamiento en la parte alta de la
atmósfera
esa señal de enfriamiento se propaga
hacia la parte baja de la atmósfera y
ayuda en el verano austral a balancear
parcialmente la señal de aumento de
temperatura que provoca el calentamiento
global el calentamiento global trata de
que la antártica se caliente y por otro
lado el agujero ozono trata de que la
antártica se enfríe lo que sucede en
antártica es un juego de balanceo entre
ambos
la razón que explica por qué la
antártica se está calentando menos que
el ecuador menos que el polo es
justamente la influencia este efecto
secundario climatológico que el agujero
de ozono tiene eso no suena tan mal pero
siempre efectos secundarios y la mayoría
de efectos secundarios nunca son buenos
y esta no es una excepción cuál es el
problema la antártica se está calentando
más lento que el ecuador y cuando eso
sucede la diferencia de temperatura
entre el ecuador
y la antártica comienza a aumentar y eso
qué importa sucede que las corrientes de
viento y las corrientes marinas son al
final flujos convectivos qué significa
eso dependen de la diferencia de
temperatura entre el ecuador y el polo
si esa diferencia se mantiene estable
los vientos se mantienen estables y esa
diferencia cambia como ha estado
cambiando las últimas décadas y seguirá
cambiando en el futuro se producen
anomalías circulatorias cambian los
patrones de viento y eso justamente lo
que ha estado sucediendo en torno a la
antártica y de hecho en todo el
hemisferio sur la gráfica que parece
ahora en pantalla muestra en color rojo
las zonas en torno a la antártica en la
que los vientos se han intensificado
son más fuertes los vientos en esa zona
enorme del hemisferio sur esos vientos
más fuertes que durante las últimas
décadas se han fortalecido son los que
han traído las aguas desde el norte
hacia las costas de la antártica son
esos los vientos responsables de que la
antártica esté perdiendo hielo y en
último término son responsables de que
el nivel del mar en todo el mundo esté
aumentando más rápido
y hay algo peor sucede que encima del
anillo rojo aparece otro anillo
circumpolar azul ese anillo azul indica
las zonas del hemisferio sur en la que
los vientos han disminuido de intensidad
un poco más tenue todavía más al norte y
acerca del ecuador hay otro anillo rojo
que indica intensificación de vientos
que es lo que quiero decir los patrones
de viento en todo el mundo los patrones
de viento especialmente del hemisferio
sur han cambiado por cosas que han
sucedido en la antártica no solamente un
cambio de viento cuando los vientos
cambian cambian las nubes y los vientos
se intensifican aumenta la nubosidad y
cuando cambian las nubes cambian las
lluvias
este mapa por ejemplo muestra las zonas
en rojo donde las lluvias han aumentado
en las últimas décadas y en azul las
zonas del mundo
en particular del hemisferio sur donde
las lluvias han disminuido si se fijan
hay un manchón azul muy intenso en la
zona centro-sur de chile
ciudades como valdivia temuco puerto
montt han perdido en las últimas cuatro
décadas más del 20% de sus lluvias esto
no es una cosa que va a pasar es algo
que ya pasó
es extraordinario que una disminución
tan agresiva en las lluvias un cambio
tan dramático en el clima sea
consecuencia de cosas que pasaron en la
antártica y esto nos lleva como a
resumir lo que está sucediendo
en la antártica están interactuando el
calentamiento global y el agujero de
ozono
ambos provocan cambios en los patrones
de viento y esos cambios esas anomalías
en los vientos son de alcance
hemisférico afectan todo el hemisferio
todo chile y naturalmente el desierto de
atacama esos vientos cuando se
intensifican en las zonas cercanas a la
antártica han movilizado enormes
volúmenes de agua y esa agua cerca de la
costa antártica es la que está ayudando
a que el nivel del mar se acelere el
aumento del nivel del mar es
responsabilidad en alguna medida de esos
cambios en intensidad de los vientos por
otro lado esas mismas anomalías en los
vientos han cambiado los patrones de
nubosidad
qué significa eso que los cambios de
lluvias de la ciudad donde cada uno de
nosotros vive dependen de cosas que ha
pasado en la antártica la antártica no
es solamente un continente para admirar
no solamente un continente para
maravillarse sino que es un continente
del que depende el clima las lluvias la
nubosidad la radiación
exactamente todo el clima de nuestro
hemisferio está conectado con la
antártica con uno dice que nuestro
destino depende de lo que le pase a la
antártica no está haciendo poesía está
siendo literal
las cosas que pasan en la antártica
nunca se quedan en la antártica muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]